according to the ABC News affiliate in
Pittsburgh Senator John fetterman just
sent a letter to the CEO of Norfolk
Southern Railway urging the company to
help residents of darling Township
according to the Pittsburgh Capital star
Senator fetterman just introduced
legislation in the Senate aimed at
preventing future train derailments like
the one we saw in East Palestine but in
reality Senator fetterman did neither of
those things because for the past two
weeks he's been isolated in a psych ward
allegedly for depression as he has
struggled to recover from a major stroke
it is troubling that some staffer one
presumes has appointed himself senator
in fetterman's place